[Music]
from Matthew Vaughn the English action
director who's not Guy Ritchie comes a
James Bond movie with more cursing I
look like I give blood and but sags or
at least more explicit but sex in an
action spy comedy parody why a satire
thriller that left audiences saying man
I did not expect that movie to be as
good as it was
Kingsman the Secret Service when a suave
British secret agent who's definitely
not James Bond trains a young Protege -
definitely not become the next James
Bond supervised by an old authority
figure who's definitely not in and
helped by a gadget wizard who's
definitely not Q to fight a bald super
villain in a mountain lair who's
definitely not low felled the only way
to convince you that you're not watching
an actual James Bond movie is to
constantly remind you that you're not if
you like spy movies
I always felt the old Bond films were
only as good as the villain the powerful
youth they something really bad fun they
saying that kind of movie buff
what's-his-name JB as in James Bond
we get it meet eggsy your average London
tough guy who's also a trained marine
parkour expert former gymnastics champ
pickpocket and stunt driver when he
pisses off the kind of British guys you
need closed captioning to understand you
fit you can check a box we won't do
nothing just cuz I've got this banging
eggsy's mum you're looking for a novel
rim border on the chorus which straight
he'll use a magical get-out-of-jail-free
necklace to join the Kingsmen a secret
agency foreign violent rich aristocrats
who answer to no one kill anybody they
think is a threat and ask you to murder
your own dogs who join their ranks
you know the good guys shoot the dog
watch them square off with an equally
over-the-top bad guy in Richmond
Valentine a man hell-bent on stopping
global warming with an equally
over-the-top plan by giving away evil
SIM cards which he just assumes everyone
will know how to replace and use that
are programmed to make everyone in the
world kill each other through brain
waves or something
unless Richmond puts an easily
detectable chip in your brain that he
can use to kill you instantly which
every world leader agrees to for some
reason yet somehow the dumbest part of
this patently ridiculous evil plan is
Sam Jackson's distracting Tweety Bird
meets Mike Tyson boys you HOT totally of
the free but I am here I'm pretty sure
the director was scared to tell them
that that idea was stupid so strap in
for all the gadgets blatant product
placement
I'll have the Big Mac plate and Myrtle
wide entry you love about the Bond films
but with even more boring snooty
Britishness like extreme politeness I'm
so sorry
Nonna's make you mad male fashion advice
a bespoke suit every peg an Oxford is
any formal shoe with open lacing basket
requires top hat the gentlemen
traditionally wears the Signet on his
left hand and really specific drink
orders either $62 more in 1815
Napoleonic brandy and fortified with a
martini gin not vodka
obviously stirred for 10 seconds while
glancing at an unopened bottle of them
thank you you're not a man we get it
starring the Kingsmen speech hot Austin
Powers Stanley Tucci ish King Arthur in
the Knights of the rectangle
professor Joker the Westboro Baptist
Church blades of glory and then L Jack
the Kings man that movie came out of
nowhere one notable absence from the red
carpet was Iggy Azalea still missing
well at least some good came out of this
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers manners maketh man my suit is
black not Straight Outta Compton you
we're only supposed to blow the bloody
doors of all we had to do was follow the
damn train CJ drop that zero and get
with hero